[Music]
if tenant is the next doctor what were
your thoughts be on that see i notice
you're wording that very carefully
because i've gone on a record multiple
places saying i have no opinion until
it's confirmed and so you're wording
your question as well if it was
confirmed then what would your opinion
be sneaky nice try not answering it
look
it would be a bad idea
i am actually you know what screw it
let's let's dig into this uh a little
bit
the idea of bringing back david tennant
to play the doctor again is a bad idea
it is a fundamentally bad idea and
before anyone shows up in the comments
telling me oh well the curator said you
could he could revisit old faces like i
know that it's not a question of they
can't do it because of xyz it's all made
up they can come up with a narrative
justification for why they should do it
that doesn't make it a good idea and the
other thing i've seen people go like oh
well he's not going to be playing the
10th doctor again it's going to be david
tennant reinterpreting the doctors who
would be a different doctor not just
doing his old version like yeah sounds
good still a bad idea this kind of
cyclical recursive
masturbatory nonsense i just i'm
knocking stuff over
this is what i dread for doctor who this
is the exact reason why i don't want
russell t davies to spend any time
retconing the timeless child as much as
i hate it because stop looking back move
forward and i don't care if you'd be
playing a different version of the
doctor casting tenant to play the doctor
again is a retrograde move it is looking
back instead of trying to progress and
whatever you feel about chibnall's time
and i have not liked most of it
he
did try and move things forward did it
work no but it is healthier for this
show and for its future to find a way to
move forward than to start looking back
and just jerking off its own freaking
continuity
fan service wankery the whole idea
be a terrible notion and i've seen a
million things like oh well you'd only
do one series oh it would just be a
couple of specials and that would be
it's a bad idea
i don't care how you package it i don't
care what you wrap it in fundamentally
it is a bad idea and it is unhealthy for
the state of the franchise
don't do it
and don't tell me any reasons why you
think i should be more optimistic about
the idea i'm not
it is the kind of thing i dread
doctor who doing
and i have for a long time
i'm very exasperated this stream
i hope people are getting entertainment
out of that
i was just camering on the 60th oh i
fully expect him to show up in the 60th
um
that i that i don't doubt and would not
have a problem with i'm fine with
multi-doctor stories
but like that's not what people are
talking about
feel free to decide if this is too
potentially spoilery but the david
tennant coming back is the 14th doctor
rumors flying right now there's nothing
to indicate we should be taking those
seriously is there honestly as much as
i'd love david
i hope they don't go there no there is
absolutely nothing to indicate there are
people who are claiming oh the leak
source has been right about other stuff
without actually providing information
as to who the leak source is or you know
it
it's
it's a game of telephone
like it could be anything
from
he is going to appear in the 60th
anniversary and that has been twisted by
you know it by being leaked in a in a
slightly off form
uh it could be that
um
or it could just have been pulled out of
the ether from fans who saw that um
russell t davis was coming back and
they're like oh maybe tenant and then
they start talking about as if it
actually will because the conversation
can shift from
oh well maybe this would be hap maybe
this would happen to wouldn't it be cool
if this happened too i bet this will
happen to this is happening like it's a
it's a standard
like self-creating rumor mill
progression
uh since
man this this really did become the
topic of the discord since tenant being
cast as the next doctor is unlikely and
a bad idea thank you uh what would you
think of him reprising his role as 10
throughout a future season i.e
not just for an anniversary special for
some tiny whiny shenanigans alongside
whichever new doctor we get or any other
previous doctors no i do not think any
doctor especially a fan favorite like
tenant
should be brought back on anything other
than a one-off basis
um weaving him throughout a future
season is just going to beg the
comparison to whoever the current doctor
is and ignite all the more divides about
why why won't you just give us another
series with tenant if you're gonna have
more the one exception i'll make is i
i'm shocked this has not happened
uh already
i would be okay
if they wanted to bring in
the metacrisis doctor
that uh
is living with rose in the parallel
dimension now when i say bring in i
don't mean take over the role of the
doctor i don't mean that at all but i
mean given that he is human that he has
been earthbound and that it is now
oh god like 15 years later or whatever
seeing how he's changed seeing how he's
different see it's funny the reason i
say it's funny that this hasn't happened
yet is
i kind of made the ins the assumption
that half the reason to even create that
situation where there was a completely
separate doctor who it's established
formerly would age would be able to
bring david tennant back
at a later date and not worry about
having to cover for the fact that he is
visibly older
um which is an issue that wasn't so much
of a problem in multi-doctor stories
back in the classic era because the
definition was so low but these days it
shows you can tell honestly you could
kind of tell in the day of the doctor he
looked older
again that's not like he's aging quite
well but
i always kind of assumed that was the
point of creating the metacrisis doctor
to be able to do that
and they still haven't so
i'd be up for that i don't want it to
dominate like a season-long story but if
i don't know
for a finale or a one-off or a special
if they wanted to touch on that that's
probably what i'd be most okay with in
terms of the idea of bringing him back
for anything other than like the 60th
anniversary